I recommend to the
elite of the Russian Federation Gather the [ __ ] of
your youths send them to war And
when you go to the funeral When you
start burying them, people will say
everything is fair now and when the elite children
smear themselves with creams and show it on
Instagram There are YouTubes and so on and  of
ordinary people, children come in zinc
torn to pieces and when a mother cries
under her son or like a
video was sent to me here a father sits
near his son’s coffin and says Vladimir
Vladimirovich I understand that you
didn’t give a general, but my son didn’t  the
son of this grandfather, he is torn to
shreds, there are pieces of meat with the ground And the
bastard in the United Arab Emirates, he
twists
this bifurcation with his ass, it’s all How it can
end It’s like in the seventeenth year of the
Revolution, when the Soldiers first stand up
and after that their loved ones will become
in vain To think that there are hundreds of them
there will probably be hundreds of thousands of them now, the
relatives of those killed
will probably be hundreds of thousands, we
can’t get away from this, and if at
the beginning of the
special operation they had conditional 500 tanks
45,000 tanks, if they have
20 thousand people able to fight skillfully and now they know how to fight
400 thousand people, how can we
militarize it turns out the other way around
hell knows how now the political creed has militarized the
motherland, I love
Putin, I obey Shoigu, the
judge didn’t have to
fight, we’ll continue to fight, as a matter of fact